welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
Italian stallion Sylvester Stallone back
on our screens is Rambo it's time to
break down everything that you need to
know about the film and sending rambo
last blood or rambo number 5 is i think
it should be called is a blast from
start to finish and throughout this
video i'm going to be discussing the
major plot points and giving my review
of the film as a whole
i've seen this movie picking up a lot of
negative press online from outlets so
make sure you stick around until the end
hear my thoughts on why i think they're
all wrong there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the film yet and don't want to
know what happens then i highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way i
just want to give a huge thank you for
quickness video now let's get into a
breakdown of rambo last blood the film
picks up over 10 years after the events
of rambo 4 and the titular character is
living a simple life on the farm that we
last saw him walking towards rambo looks
after his friend and her niece Gabrielle
and the to have a close-knit bond that
has finally brought some happiness to
the characters life Gabrielle's father
up and left her a decade earlier and
she's been desperate to find him to ask
why he up sticks on her and her dying
mother
so when words of his whereabouts is
given to her she travels to Mexico to
meet him after he pretty much slams the
door in her face and tells her that he
didn't care about her or a mother
Gabrielle goes to drown his sorrows with
the childhood friend who just so happens
to be working for a gang of human
traffickers and they take Gabrielle
prisoner which sets off John on a
mission to try and track her down it's a
really slow start to the film that
flashes out the world that our
characters exist in and from the
beginning you get the feeling that this
won't have a happy ending now whilst I
have seen this compared to take in ba
the premise there's actually very little
that similar rambo is less
indestructible than he was in prior
movies and his first attempt to rescue
Gabrielle goes terribly and he ends up
getting a deep scar cut into his face
that is a reminder of its failure this
scar is the mark of the Martinez
brothers the villains of the piece and
they too do the same to Gabriel's face
treating her as
humane is possible due to the disrespect
that they feel at the hands of Rambo
they brutally beat him but leave him
alive so that he can constantly think
about all of the pain and torment that
she's going through these guys aren't
your cookiecutter villains and they make
a James Bond body seem like Gandhi their
dark twisted and lack a sense of decency
which instantly makes you gravitate to
Rambo and similar to the prior film you
really get involved when the killings
finally start at about the halfway point
of the film after receiving help from a
journalist named Carmen Rambo is able to
find Gabrielle and rescue her but on the
way home she dies shedding a tear after
Rambo discusses how proud he is over
it's a really heartbreaking moment and
it's a turn that I didn't expect purely
because I was pretty much assuming this
to be like taken and for everything to
end with a nice bow wrapped around it
devastated Rambo doesn't take the high
road and decides that the best course of
action is to take revenge and the
Martinez brothers and the gang he and
Gabrielle Santee say that they feel like
they've had their hearts go out and
Rambo wants to do this to the brothers
the last 45 minutes of the film pretty
much becomes the final hour of Breaking
Bad season 5 and it's awesome to watch
the character setting up traps home
alone style purely because he knows that
he can bait their mouth and make them
suffer
Rambo travels back to Mexico but heads
to the Martinez brother that cut the
mark on his face and dumps his head in
the road on the way to his house
basically painting a target on his back
that says follow me into the tunnels I
promise it's fun down here the gang
follow him back and Rambo unleashes all
the airs of rage that he's been keeping
the lid on completely decimating them in
what is arguably one of the best action
scenes in the entire franchise it's up
there with the 50 Cal moment in the
previous film and is completely
incredible to watch it's rare that we
see an r-rated action movie that really
goes to this depth and watching Rambo
completely tear through everyone is as
satisfying as ever during the struggle
Rambo takes a couple of shots but it
keeps on fighting which sort of plays
into the end which I'll get into later
he finally kills all of Martinez's men
refusing to kill Martinez until there's
no one left standing and in the barn he
asks if he knows what it's like to have
his Hocker out before driving his knife
into the villains chest pulling his
heart out with his hands and letting it
beat in front of the car
out there before he dies it's such a
gory over-the-top moment that is the
perfect final kill for the franchise
let see know that Rambo has and always
will be one of the most badass heroes of
all time badly wounded
Rambo climbs to his rocking chair on his
porch and sits rocking back and forth as
he bleeds out his gut shot which cuts
two credits and a montage of the movies
and the franchise thus ending the film
now I've seen a lot of people asking
whether he was alive or dead at the end
and for those who didn't hang around
until after the credits we do see the
character get up
saddle up his horse and ride off Rambo
says in the narration that though his
family and the ones they cares about are
gone he's still going to keep going in
order to carry on their memory he will
fight on in order to keep them alive in
some form or another he's not giving up
and he's not going to stop even with
that wound Rambo is unstoppable so I
highly doubt that this will be the last
we see of him I'm not the only one
either as when promoting the film
Sylvester Stallone himself said that
there is potential for more films after
last blood and that this is only the
beginning so whilst the wound is pretty
bad it looks like we will be getting
more films in the future with the
character so bets call the next one
Rambo new blood look I don't know I
don't make up the titles yet but there's
definitely an opportunity for more down
the line and now on to my review and why
media outlets are unnecessarily giving
negative reviews on Rambo last blood I'm
gonna be focusing on IGN mainly who gave
the film a 4.5 out of 10 but I've seen a
lot of criticism that the reviewer made
repeated on Rotten Tomatoes quite a lot
from other reviewers what it boils down
to is that the movie is apparently too
offensive for today's current political
climate and as always it's a small
minority of people who are massively
offended making all of the noise when I
guarantee that 90% of the population
don't really care the reviewer actually
went on to say that Rambo was badass but
in all word like most Rambo movies which
to me pretty much highlights that they
haven't seen the other films first blood
was about a predominantly white enemy
and Rambo 3 even had the character
teaming up with the people of
Afghanistan to take on the white Russian
forces the reviewer flat-out says that
Rambo isn't needed in 2019 which I
completely disagree with and here's why
when everything is deemed too offensive
Rambo is exactly what we need Rambo is a
film that doesn't care about his
sensibilities or feelings
it's in-your-face aggressive and if it's
offending you then you probably need to
get a grip because at the end of the day
it's just a movie I don't know how these
people even leave their house if an
action movie scares them and seems
problematic and I know that the majority
of people that are fans of Rambo will
watch this and enjoy it I feel like the
negative reviews have been because
people have tried to put their own
personal politics on a movie that
doesn't really care and is doing its own
thing if you're going to review a piece
of entertainment you should push your
personal feelings to the side and judge
something on its merits rather than if
you think it aligns with your personal
beliefs as it's not supposed to Rambo is
about taking an extreme situation
turning it up to 11 and going all out to
me it's ridiculous that so-called film
critics are crying about the violence in
the movie when it's always been part of
the franchise who goes to a Rambo movie
expects a Rambo movie gets a Rambo movie
and then complains that it's a Rambo
movie it's just I rolling to me and I
think that IGN especially should have
been more selective about who they chose
to review the film this person clearly
gets offended by violence Sonoma or what
happened in the movie they were never
going to enjoy it and that's totally
fine as well they don't have to enjoy it
but when you're using someone as an
ambassador for your website you need to
have someone who will have a balanced
opinion rather than a skewed view of
what should and shouldn't be in a film
the movie isn't made for them the world
doesn't revolve around them it's simply
not for them not every movie is for
everyone and if you're offended by Rambo
then it's because you're not its
audience you're not the person it's made
for I personally don't want to see
Downton Abbey it's not for me I'm not
gonna review it because I know I'm gonna
give it a bad score even if technically
it's a great film and fans
even if I did reviewer I still wouldn't
call it the r-word as I think this would
show my narrow view and understanding of
the film and what its content is I know
this is coming off really runny but it
just annoys me seeing people trying to
constantly be woke and get offended on
behalf of other people when this is just
entertainment at the end of the day if
you've seen Rambo for then you know
exactly what to expect
why have you went into the movie with
the expectations that it's going to be
transcending and an action movie that
completely changes the world it's
completely stupid and I'm getting really
whiny here and I don't really want to be
but IGN massively messed up and if you
like Rambo chances are you know what to
expect and will love this movie
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from it if
you agree with me or disagree with me
then make sure you leave a comment below
and if you enjoy this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out my breakdown of this weekend's
are the big release ad astra which would
be linked at the end I go over
everything you need to know about the
movie so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and you can follow
me on twitter at definition YT it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this well so just
wanna let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Rambo last blood in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on October the 15th
and the blue arrow be shipped out from
the end whoever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone he takes part
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you